Exciting frontiers in quorum sensing is to actually figure out,
how does this work,
not in a flask in a laboratory?
So how is quorum sensing playing out
in biology, in life?
So I think one area of particular high interest right
now is the microbiome.
So what's also been learned in the past twenty or so years,
is that every higher organism lives in a fantastic
community with bacteria.
So,
for example,
in the human gut,
there are 10^14 bacteria in there, 600 different species,
and they are giving us life.
And they're doing all these processes, and helping us digest our food, and educate our immune system, and
make all kinds of micronutrients.
And so these bacteria that are living in our gut,
for example,
are keeping us alive. Quorum sensing has to be happening in there.
And so what I wonder,
is 10^14 bacteria, 600 species,
all using their own blends of molecules,
plus there's curves and flow, and my human genetics, and what I eat,
and when I ate it, and there's space, and there's time, and how in the
world can quorum sensing be kept straight? Like, how are these bacteria
not getting confused?
You know,
how do they actually do the correct jobs in time, in space,
in the face of bacteria that they're cooperating with and
bacteria that they're enemies with?
And somehow, here I am, they're doing it. And so
I would just love--
and I think there's a big effort to try-- to understand how does quorum sensing happen in
mixed species, in real time,
when conditions are not ideal,
like in a flask in a lab?
And I think figuring that out is a really hard and wonderful
problem,
and I think that's what scientists are going to have their eyeballs on going into these next
ten years.